not your end damon
right good afternoon everybody uh
welcome to the grow school today
committee
um people come outside
um no apologies received chair before we
make a start can i just
inform members that this is being
streamed live to youtube
i'm also going to record this just for
the purposes of the
the minutes as chair this meeting is
being recorded
thanks damon thank you for that um do we
have any declarations of interest
no good
minutes of the last meeting to approve
as a correct record
and the chair to sign the informal
minutes
gross school security um do we all are
we all happy with the minutes
yeah yep excellent
this is nice and easy too right okay
item four
um growth strategy to further discuss
the new growth strategy and receive a
presentation
from the director of growth and economic
development uh jill
callingham and carl tua i guess
um are you with us welcome welcome jill
welcome
carl it's noon
afternoon i can't see you i have to
change my screen so i can see oh you're
there
sorry if it helps you i can um tell you
someone's put their hand up to speak
without
that help yeah have you seen it on my
screen thanks damon yeah thanks for that
kids are doing home schooling saw me be
big device
i'm missing someone to use this um
okay jill over to you okay thank you um
yeah i'm i'm doing a presentation on
where we are with the growth strategy um
and explain the progress we've made and
when we expect it
uh to be done so i'm just going to share
my screen
if that's okay okay
she says trying to do that
oh here we go let me know when you can
see something
right i can see i can see it now okay
thank you
so um the growth strategy is
um a document that will will set
how we will look to support our economy
um particularly around post covid
19 should we ever get to that position
there with me
some reason i can't move it forward oh
here we go
um so we have uh started developing
the strategy we're quite a long way
through it now
um and there are seven priority areas
that we've identified
and they're listed there and within that
we've got business engagement and
business support
skills and we've created a another
strategy to deal with skills because
that's quite an in-depth
document given that we're coming out of
a co post covered world
eventually uh and then the visitor
economy which is
is new to north east uh derbyshire it's
it's something new that's coming within
and we've done a separate visitor
economy
document which we'll be looking at later
on in this uh this session
um town center regeneration really
important
um because our whole time centers are
changing
um businesses are going to
larger businesses are going out of um
there's really lost ebonems and those
sorts of things so
how our town center works is changing a
lot and we need to address that in this
strategy
um inward investment and that's linked
to how we use our assets
as well and it's about how we get um
people investing in our areas um to
develop them and to make and regenerate
them um
we've got major sites development ones
that are important to northeast
derbyshire
and they're not forgetting a lot of our
areas made up of the rural agricultural
economy and how do we help support those
businesses
so um when we do this work we need to
and one of the reasons it's taken quite
a little bit longer than we'd we'd have
hoped
is because there is a kind of hierarchy
in
in how this works and d2n2 who are
the local enterprise partnership and any
money to support
business or growth comes through the
local enterprise partnership
have been looking at their own recovery
strategy
and we have been waiting for that to
come out to help inform
our strategy because we then know they
they've got the ability to do all the
major research
and we can use that in our own strategy
and also in a more finer detail we've
got
the derbyshire county council and the
the derbyshire enterprise
um economic um partnership
that looks particularly at derbyshire
and what it needs
so those two documents we've been
waiting to come out to help conformers
the recovery strategy from the lep got
approved just before christmas
um and you can see they've got three
main areas they're looking at which is
uh low carbon growth productivity and
connected
inclusion and they're expecting money to
come through government to support those
areas
and then uh the the derbyshire
economic partnership um is looking at
five
key priorities around place uh
industry visual economy enabling
infrastructure to sort of more better
joined up and inward investment
so we've we're in the process of of
just finalizing our economic strategy to
make sure they're aligned to this and
aligned to what we need
know we need at a local level
um what you're finding is there are
cross-cutting themes across all of this
and that is we are moving as an economy
towards more low-carbon reducing climate
change
and how we can use that
to upskill some of our residents
and to support that net carbon um
emissions by 2050 it's a real
opportunity
um and a lot of us are all working from
home now
the way we do businesses is changing
so um it's about increasing this is
looking forward about increasing that
digital technology and how we use it in
the business in our businesses
i would say don't forget in all this we
are a manufacturing area
and even in manufacturing digital is
becoming more to the forefront and it's
about how we use that so we're not
losing
what we do well but it's also looking
forward and about how we future proof
that
coving 19 as we all know has had a
massive impact on
businesses across the country north east
derbyshire is no different
and what we're looking in the in this
strategy is about how to support the
recovery of that
the landscape is going to change um
you know our town centres are going to
change we've got to reimagine some of
those things that we're doing and we're
trying
we're looking to address that in this
strategy within the
strategy and under the strategy there
will be action plans about how we do
that
and we're working on those just at the
moment
um that leads us to we're hoping to
finalize the growth strategy
uh by the end of this month so we're
just waiting for the last
latest bits of information we're going
to consult with we've been consulting
with stakeholders as we've been going on
but we're going out to
consult in early february on that and
that includes members and
various other people we then need to
look at that and incorporate those
comments
and then get it through the cabinet
approval process now looking at that by
the time we've done all that we're
looking probably for
april this year for that to be approved
we get lots of comments back or
you know we need to do some changes that
might get pushed back but it's important
that we get this document right and it
actually meets the needs
so that's where we are on the growth
strategy and i probably haven't got very
much more
at this stage um i'm not happy to take
um any questions there's paul and i and
councillor renick here
thank you jill thanks very much for that
right
everybody um has anybody got any any
questions i can see john's hand on my
screen john
do you want to come with your question
yeah thanks for that jill it's
i'm quite interested in the general
growth and we have waited quite a long
time
something to come forward and i guess
pandemic has put
that on hold for a little while i'm
particularly keen on
are you going to attach some performance
indicators to the growth strategy
like generate 10 million pounds
investment or generate an extra 5 000
jobs something tangible that you can add
to
the to the waiting that you've given us
they're all nice things to do
digital and all the rest of it but have
you got some tangible results you're
looking for out of the growth strategy
if i take that first and then i'll let
carl come in with uh because he's a
performance indicator man
um so there will be an action plan
attached to this about where we're
looking for
um in areas that we need to take forward
so be that you know investing in or
doing
work with school children to get them
digital skills or older people to get
digital skills
so there'll be those sorts of
performance indicators
i think investment in an area is uh
difficult at this this time but it's
certainly something we can have a think
about and have a
look at so when we've got the action
plans
it might be worth the delivery plans it
might be worth having a
look at those and we'll have to see what
we can put performance indicators
against those
carl have you got something to add to
that uh just that
all strategies will have an action plan
because there's no point in the strategy
about an action plan and
an action plan then you have to have a
kpi to manage the
action plan and so we will have um
those kpis associated with it we'll have
to make sure that those
capabilities that we can influence so we
will
because that's something that might be
outside of our control but what we can
say
and where we'll apply np programs for
the clay cross town investment plan
is that we will look to deliver whatever
the products are within that and that
will have
specific kpis attached to those and
there will be outputs associated with
those projects
thanks nick so you your handle
yeah thanks hi everyone um
jill obviously i think um uh
the the thing to get over the line here
is what our remit is as a district
councillor
um because it's so i think we we all
want to get carried away
and do uh you know some great things but
obviously there's other there's other
entities involved here d2n2 county
uh government initiatives there's loads
of things
um is it it always seems to me when we
talk about these things that we get
carried away and we end up falling into
remits by others um and
really staying true and understanding
what our remit is as a district what we
can deliver
and how far you know what how far can we
push it as a district council
you know um thinking outside the box and
and really where should we be drawing
the lines because
are we going to get too carried away in
some areas
that is that's an interesting one so um
councils have specific roles in
supporting
local people and as
uh and um when it comes to supporting
town centres and things like that
the issue you have is one of
resource we are a smaller council
and we are a two-tier system which
um so we really need to work very
closely with derbyshire county council
in delivering that
but that's the same for all of the
councils
and there is this sort of golden thread
which i think
you're referring to is that the money
the money to support these initiatives
comes from the lap
at the top sometimes through the county
sometimes directly to us
so we need to um
know our placement where we can best use
our
resource to support that and that's part
of this action plan that we're doing
at the moment it's about where we target
our resource
carl have you got anything where's that
car going who's this
those on the point i was making earlier
about the kpis we need to make sure the
kpis and the work that we're doing are
all stuff that's within our control if
we try
and take on dcc's responsibilities for
the highways well
it's just not going to work it's not
going to happen so
kind of linking back to what point i was
trying to make about the kpis is we need
it needs to be within our gift within
our control
and it needs to be on the sort of the
same page really in terms of the funders
so the money
certainly comes through the labs and
they will have identified some
priorities
thankfully those priorities they've
identified so that are in sync with the
priorities that we've identified so that
sort of links really well in terms of
their willing to fund those sort of
projects and that's the sort of projects
we want to fund
so and absolutely we do need to keep our
feet in the ground as you rise
nigel can bring you in question i'm
guessing
yeah thanks yet uh it's very similar to
what what makes your stats really
i was sort of thinking along them lines
you know about how
our role in all this and i have been
involved
with the county at on with the laps and
looking at
the d2n2 and now the money's allocated
and and obviously that's the thing but
we need
we've got our projects like the avenue
or or by waters
i'm just wondering for our uh
knowledge benefit or whatever this group
uh
what what our bids our are what's what
we've submitted i know there's a big one
for them to have just said uh and and
what how do we
oversee all that i suppose is my
question uh because we're only a small
cog in a in a big
system really as a district so
that is it's a really interesting one
that so depending on what the
scheme is there are benefits in doing it
as a more
collaborative approach so
as we move forward the um
[Music]
the economic part derbyshire economic
partnership
are doing key themes uh well
as districts we all get together to bid
for money
and use that and and that's quite common
it's quite common when we're doing for
skills
that we all club together because we can
make a a better bid
what you find is when when bidding
family they want
things of a certain size another
district can't
do that so we have to work in
partnership with the other districts in
the county to do that
and we've had some success with that
which i'm sure carl can talk about
the work that jane's done um
and then some projects are large enough
that can go in as uh individual projects
so the avenue
as you say is one of them however we
can't deliver that on our own
we need to do that with county so there
are very few
projects that we can deliver
independently
of working with partners and it's those
partnerships have become really
important
when you're looking at uh growth and and
recovery
thanks joe uh lee lee can i bring you in
please
yeah yeah i agree uh obviously we do
need to work with uh with other partners
um how do we go on uh which seems to be
the point with the avenue i think
um when those partners don't seem to
pull in pulling away but it affects our
district
i'm gonna let carolyn answer that one
that's fine yeah a very good question um
counselor hearthstone
just first i just want to well well
thank you to jill and carl um
today i know this has been a long time
coming it
that the um the document we produced you
know was started juice
beginning of the year um it hasn't
changed very much
in fact some of the things that we've
been looking at in terms of town centre
regeneration federal
facilities upskilling um are actually
being accelerated um due to coverage so
some things that some of our ambitions
are now become national ambitions and
but
as jill just mentioned what we found
is that we had opportunities uh during
kobut to
certain bits of funding um accelerated
funding and we weren't really in a
position because we haven't got a lot of
business planning done for some of the
aspirations we have so so the importance
of this first strategy is that we've
been now the team's developing
jill's on board which is being brilliant
and we've actually um
we've had a very busy summer with the
clay crosstown deal
but um we recognize now we we are
ambitious we need to put into
business cases so when funding is
available
and there's you know the chance to
announce only a few weeks ago
more town centre funding is we want to
make sure we're in a position
to do more than clay cross we can get
get around
uh you know killer martial kingston drum
beard and high streets as well
so that's important and influencing
israel i think
um as you know as chair of this
committee and one of my first
drives um as when i looked through the
um
the regional growth strategies at d2n2 i
didn't see the district featuring very
highly
in their list of priorities or or
projects
um the good news again is that dr jill's
experience in this area she's done a lot
of
nothing before she came here and we're
hopefully
uh moving our agenda at their table by
having these this growth strategy and
the
all the other projects underneath it and
just to let you know
we've got 30 40 different projects that
we're working on currently
this forms this glossage i don't think
we're just not anything just wait for
this strategy to be written
we've been getting on the job doing some
big projects including
the avenue and the town center you know
25 million pounds
town deal and many other things on top
of actually helping businesses with
business support and
the support grants are getting out in
record
time so so you're right it's influencing
and we've not i don't think we've been
at the top of the agenda regionally and
we need to change that
and i think that we're in a much
stronger position now
to make that happen thank you
thank you for that um
has anybody else got the handle let's
have a quick click
no uh other personal oh
sorry diana would you like to ask a
question
your unmute by the way it's just a quick
one i mean people are abandoning about
the avenue and the project and work
going on there
avenues quite dear to my heart is in my
world
but i don't i haven't really been kept
in the loop about what is going on over
there
other than our last meeting so you'd be
quite interested to know
if anything has been going on or has
decided for what's happening over there
so i i think um this leads into uh
councillor hart sean's uh email so there
is a um
one of the the things that we're looking
to do is get that better relationship
with
uh derbyshire county council
and the um and the mp
and part of that work is about where
we've got
issues um stopping things is about
raising those so that they can
can be dealt with and we've start just
started that process so it's just
bedding in
it's not as slick as it can but you will
it will come to that now i think
councillor
uh rough you came to one of those
meetings i think when we discussed the
avenue yeah and
yeah and so that that's this it's the
it's the same nothing's made it's quite
clear what the plan is for the avenue
because it's already been set out
what we're here to try and do is try and
unblock some of those things that have
stopped it going so one of those
is about getting that southern access
road in and you know
putting in with um to the left
um again it's been very difficult during
recovery so we're carrying on with doing
those things is
this a smaller piece of work with
working with the land trust
the school has gone in for its uh
planning application for the new primary
school in there
so there's those sorts of things that
happening which i and
i know we've we've discussed in in that
meeting so that's
regeneration is a slower it's quite a
slow process in some ways it's sort of
it takes a long leading so once the
plans are said it's about how do we
deliver those plans and that's what
we're working through at the moment
where were any of the newer suggestions
taken on board
was because the original site and what
was put
out for this site was quite poor in in
my view and i think they have lost
a golden opportunity for what can happen
on that site
so did anything change from any of the
suggestions that were made at that
meeting
well some of those were suggestions
around how we use the
uh community assets weren't they and
about what the land
they they are looking at that it's about
how we make that place
um better and again that is around
funding
and it's about having those plans in
place to try and support that so the
land trusts are well on board
with that already
thank you okay john you're going to
ask a question yes one for carolyn
more than anyone um you did mention that
you got
40 projects on the go caroline which is
which is good
and i know you're trying to get money
from d2m2 which was one of your themes
when he was chair
could you give us a flavor of some of
the 40 projects that you said you're
dealing with i'm
particularly interested in ones that
could be generating employment for
people
are there any of those in the in the
pipeline well we've got things like
um obviously clay crosses the biggie
then we've got to try and on on the back
of that theme we've got ope
in terms of um looking at eckinson
killer marsh and drum fielders town
centers we're doing massively there
because we won't maybe have the luxury
of having that
pounds of funding given to us and then
you would
you might have to be a bit more
imaginative in terms of being with
investment and working with partners so
i'm working on them on the uh on a
scheme at the moment um
probably not on this platform but just
to try and work with
um other other organizations that got
properties that we could help
repurpose and be part of a bigger scheme
then we've got things like kickstart
some of the things like kickstart
getting more and apprenticeships and
and working with the construction
industry on a bid there to help with
jobs and skills
but i can't remember it and call my
colleagues
but we've got a lot some of them are
smaller but we've got quite a lot of
projects including
you know and smaller projects around the
um clay cross
in terms of a couple of properties that
we're actually demolishing and buying
and repurposing so yeah there's quite
quite a lot and then there's a whole
we've got a whole uh strategy coming to
this to to to um
hobby to you as well soon around assets
about what we do with our assets and
uh just for the units are they giving us
best buy for
the right type so there's lots of little
things um
and you know out of all of them we hope
to actually either generate more income
or
or capital of some some suspect will
actually help with skills and job
creation that that's
you know and even more important at this
stage is actually
retaining and upskilling so we a we can
keep people in work
and we can actually we can actually
actually improve the skills
in our district to make sure that people
stay in here too many people leave
northeast derbyshire to work in
sheffield chesterfield and other places
so
you know and we know from speaking to um
to some employers that they can't find
the right people to do the jobs in this
area so
there's loads of yeah we've got we've
got lots of little projects on as well
i just didn't want to think that you
know we're just spending our time
writing strategies there's a lot of work
going on so our
action plan is quite well populated um i
wasn't yes i'm sorry i haven't seen the
the document that i've been looking at
for
months which has some of these actions
on it and being just
part of my recovery strategy which which
i would have thought is on our website
which has a list of certain the system
that i'm talking about
including leisure centers and there's
lots of
little things going on one of the one of
the things we can as part of
the recovery is and we should finalize
today is we're going to have some
business engagement support for for the
businesses
across our district uh so we've put that
out to tender we scored them we just
went to hear back from one of the
the consultancies applied and then today
we should decide
which of the consultants we're going to
appoint to to do that that work for us
and that's funded up until
march 2022 and it'll be
that recovery and then growth
uh to encourage so revive recover and
grow really for the businesses within
our district so that's one of the
the key things that we're doing just at
this point which is
in addition to today
what's that costing uh
it's 50 well the the range
and the consultants have gone in from so
the the cheapest is 55 the most
expensive
car i'm going to stop you there you
can't talk about procurement in
this okay so there's a range of prices
okay horses bolted
yeah i know when you're getting into
trouble with procurement sorry about
that
everybody my support meeting yeah sorry
yeah but we have got a couple of strands
where we can actually
you know bring this support into the
district directly
there's a lot of um funding at east
midlands enterprise through d2n2
the county division derbyshire
where we decided that business support
at this stage where we look about
growing
and upskilling at this time it's about
helping people to survive
um we might have some ground funding
perhaps attached and the idea is to try
and upskill people potentially digitally
and
we'll talk about tourism next and you
know some of those companies that have
moved quickly to adapt to digital
technology have been the ones that have
survived through this pandemic when the
sector itself's been on its knees
right folks can't hold nigel please
uh i'm probably looking at so here
what's our remate as a security
committee then to oversee
uh both the strategy that that
that's jill's written but also these
these other projects that are underneath
it
uh because i i i only came as you were
leaving caroline
at carolina as jay i think what you were
trying to get at were
we'll see how effective some of these
projects were and all that i'm just
wondering
what's our remit as a scooting committee
in overseeing or scrutinizing
this strategy and the other things below
it
uh yes council marker and the committee
has um the ability to scrutinize any
strategy or policy that the council is
putting in place
and comment on that strategy um and it's
a requirement to offer it up to
scrutiny for comment in terms of the
projects that sit underneath it
you've got pretty broad um ability to do
that
because you can um look at anything that
has any impact
on residents of the district or people
living in the district so
you can see that gives you a pretty wide
scope
thanks sue so you sort of you see now
at this at this point we haven't had a
great deal
to scrutinize every particularly so um
and we're just getting some sort of
the nitty-gritty part of it now where we
can actually sort of get involved
um i mean this is a comment
uh really rather than a question uh to
jill
and it's a follow-on to uh councillor
ruff's comments
we we as um elected representatives
know our areas and and our opinions
but we're only ordinary people so we
don't know the the real nitty-gritty of
stuff
but it's it's just nice to be
informed as things are happening because
you might have some local knowledge you
just might know something
say look that's a waste of money because
and that was just a comment it wasn't a
it wasn't a question or anything like
that
um does has anybody else got any
questions
uh for jill that's all is it really
happy
this got muted a few months ago maybe
six months ago
um but for me um
it's all about investment and roi um and
if
if the roi if the return on investment
is is high why don't we invest
more so therefore what is our limit of
investment
is it governed by just merely the amount
of money we've got
or is it governed by the return on
investment that we can see
um so therefore what i would be
interested in maybe from a scrutiny
point of view
is what's our total investment in this
growth strategy
you know what is it looking like and is
that and is that a
uh is that an overhead or is that an
investment that
will bring an roi um and i presume that
we will need two numbers
to talk about is that jill is that
something that we can
we can get to um well you're looking at
two different things there aren't you so
um there's the benefit that the growth
strategy
and the team bring to supporting
people um in the district and business
in the district and that's hard to put a
monetary value on because
we don't necessarily as a council get
return the
the other thing is where we invest in um
land or projects in order to get a
return and now that would be
um i'm guessing that would be dealt with
a different
scrutiny because that's about how the
council invests
its its money be it in ricknord or
northwood or you know in its own assets
so probably sue would be best to tell me
if that's
uh something that's here it goes to a
different scrutiny
can't hear you
yeah i'd have to check terms of the
reference to be sure because
what happens with the solution is that
some of the areas don't
fit neatly in one box so like for
instance some of the housing stuff
sits in the communities committee that
some of the sort of investment sort of
thing
could sit in this committee um all i'd
say is in
in terms of the committees there's an
understanding between the committees
regardless of where it sits
if another committee has an interest in
it
because they think it touches on their
area the chairs can agree
with their committees that they will
take that together or one committee will
look at it on behalf of the other
so those boundaries are very very fluid
between the terms of reference there's
some very specific things
in each committee but a lot of other
things as i say
are very fluid in where they can be
looked at does that help
yeah yeah i think i think what i'm
trying to get to is how do we know how
much to invest
how do we know you know is it is it a
hundred thousand pounds in salaries
um why is it not two hundred thousand
pounds in salaries
um should we be uh borrowing
five million pounds for an industrial
park
to um to um
to build on uh the the things that we're
talking about and
create jobs and support that that's not
a that's not a cost that's an investment
that would deliver an roi
maybe it's break even maybe it'll create
a surplus
so as a scrutiny committee what i'm
getting to is
how do we how are we going to know that
the council has pushed itself
you know what how how are we going to
know that how we go
why is the number the number and why is
it not bigger or smaller
you know so something will be presented
to us and he'll have a cost
and how do we know it's
it's the best that we can do
thanks lee i don't know it's not really
sorry i can't see
you nick nick sorry
sorry sorry luke
carol can you would you like to comment
yeah yeah a very good question counselor
it's a question that that's uh probably
yours and the economic growth team
itself would keep asking because
it is difficult when you know when we've
got um obviously constraints on budget
and a coverage crisis in the middle is
that we have to think really carefully
and and you know we haven't i have a but
we know
jill is a and has a budget for the for
the team in terms of
staff and yes we we you'll see through
the
you know hopefully the next few weeks
when we bring some of these strategies
to
um to to to full council then that there
will be somebody attached to them but
that's more for the for the staffing
which you know and it's in
itself is very important um
but in terms of the uh the bigger spend
yeah we you know i i
would like to know if i could have a
budget of x million to buy and sell
realities and that isn't going to happen
because the money isn't there so
for those you know more imaginative ways
you know looking at assets what what we
can repurpose what to get more money out
of what's working well
and then make a case for actually um you
know
going to borrowing to support this i'm
not suggesting for one minute we'd do
what a lot of
councils did is buy shopping centers um
but
you know in it there's this bits of
areas where you know
at the moment obviously we clay crosses
our focus so
we know we are putting quite a bit of
money into clay cross quite rightly so
it's an area it's identified
in great need and and that we should all
be proud to support
uh that area but but it does mean that
that's the big bad the cherry and we've
got to be more imaginative how we look
after the rest of the towns and high
streets that uh
that are not clay cross thanks
hi susie we'd like to um
i thought nick asked a really good
councillor white had
asked a really good question about um
return on investment etc
uh and i'm mindful of the last council
meeting where
it was brought to us and uh killer marsh
lesser center was um
it was agreed that the council would
take it on on
is that something we would be allowed to
scrutinize
um because obviously we are bothered
about how much
investment that that is going to cost
and are we going to get
return on investment can we scrutinize
that
come as part of the group
sue would you like to answer that
question perhaps
i don't know no that answer the question
chair but just to come back on what i
said previously and see if it does help
as i say the categories um within each
of the committees
um in terms of reference are very broad
and if i just tell you what's under the
gross scrutiny committee you'll see how
broad they are
so they have responsibility for uh
scrutiny footprints relating to
so the local enterprise enterprise
partnership and combined authorities
the business economy economic
development
regeneration asset management planning
tourism partnership and uh strategic
housing as i mentioned some cross so
uh communities has the other side of
housing and then the two catch-alls that
i was talking about any committee may
consider any matters that are important
to the health and well-being of
residents within northeast asia and you
appreciate that's a pretty broad
category and then the second point i
made where a particular issue could fall
within the functions of two or more
scrutiny committees
the chairs of the relevant scrutiny
committees following consultation with
the old
government security manager will agree
which future committee will consider the
matter
i don't know whether that helps council
cornwall's question but is it
because it does seriously come into one
of those remits
right at the end about health and
well-being so i'm i'm just wondering if
we can also
include in this sort of scrutiny on the
the the new proposal that's been brought
forward by um
by the council
um as it moves on really
if jeff i could just add to that
i mean obviously i've been in scrutiny a
long time and it's always been
um the council has always been happy for
scrutiny committees
to do this sort of work and usually you
know discussions may take place but
we've never been actually stopped at and
been involved
in what you want to get involved in
subject to those discussions
thank you sue thanks that uh councillor
whitehead
yeah just yeah just to point that
obviously roi does not necessarily have
to be financial
uh and as um sue was just reading out
there
the health and wellbeing is a is
delivering a service for the benefit of
our residents that's what
we're here to do we're not we're not
here to be making money making surplus
and
and that kind of thing uh it doesn't
mean that we can't but that shouldn't be
our uh our go-to remit
you know at the end of the day we're
here to serve people um and leisure
um is obviously forms part of um
i think a longer term strategy for for
the country that
we need to keep people active and and
off devices
and and it's things like leisure
facilities it's going to help us do that
so we we you know you know there is an
roi there
that's going to be a very difficult one
to determine obviously but
but absolutely it's not just a monetary
roi
yes thanks thanks for that negro but
that's the same any business though
isn't it really it's
it's difficult when you're making
investments
um has anybody anybody else got any
anything
for jill any more questions are you all
happy with
with with everything yeah
okay thank you jill thank you carl for
your presentation
today um be very informative
i'm sure we'll get to speak more about
it as this time goes on um
that was item four moving on to item
five and i suppose it's almost like a
continuation
um i'd like to bring in uh councillor uh
carolyn renick
um about uh to talk about a visitor
economy strategy thank you carolyn
yeah thank you right um i need to
share um my screen if i can
can you see the presentation
no not yet not yet
oh welcome yeah thank you all right
okay well this this is the first um this
economy strategy for the district and
that was really to highlight the
importance of tourism to
the economy nationally regionally and
locally and
um that's recognized
in government that is growing and um
you know we actually looked originally
what we were doing in terms of
economy and tourism and we're funding um
small amounts of money to the tourism
chesterfield tourism open the market
marketing peak district in derbyshire
but we i didn't feel we've seen a great
deal of benefit from it and some of
that's because we didn't have internal
resource to
benchmark all the tourism offer we had
here and to sell it and to
populate the various websites that we
were paying into and
it really left us unable to promote our
our district and it you know at one
point i was thinking about how do we
improve visitor attractions in this
areas in with investment
we're not there yet it is still an
ambition
and the reality is we don't have major
tourist attractions like
chatsworth or gulliver's kingdom or as
well
you know what i don't know all the other
things that uh around
the peak district and uh locally so we
really have to go back to basics to try
and understand
what our usp is and
uh that was quite difficult in terms of
you know what where are we
what do we represent and i think after
some discussion that
the best we could think of is that some
of the key selling points is that we are
very centrally located we are placed
nicely between
the peak district and the peak and all
that it has to offer and don't forget
derbyshire is huge the petership goes
all the way to manchester one area to
one end and
um we're also near two cities in
you know particularly for where i i live
in the district in ridgeway we're on the
board with sheffield and
you know i i spent a lot of time at
sheffield in terms of theaters and
and the retail opportunities so um
can you see the next screen i haven't
got
um yes yeah
yeah i'm going to scroll it up rather
than click it on
so so basically after after a bit of
time thinking that we're a
gateway this is just a draft of some of
our thoughts and it's still being
developed and tweaked so actually i'm
i'm quite interested to know what you
what you will see how you feel about
this but it was about
growing and developing you know
northeast garbage as gateway to the
peaks you know
and obviously the pieces of rich
landscape of culture heritage and rural
livery
and that you know we in northeast arch
of the perfect stepping stone
into the peak district and beyond
because that's what we do we you know we
haven't
say got the a major attraction you know
we do have some good
attractions but we also i think that
ultimately when i when we're thinking
about holiday experiences when we chat
about this as a team
is that you know i sometimes go to
places where i'm sort of in the middle
with access to and you know a number of
places you know if you if you bait
yourself
in the peak district in in baseball
you've got to try to get to buxton or to
other places so
you know some people might come to
northeast derbyshire you know it might
be slightly cheaper than the
boutique hotel in the in the central
peak district but you'll have a nice
bed and breast accommodation nice cozy
pubs you know hopefully
part of our regeneration of towns gives
us nice towns and high streets to go to
and and in the evenings you can get off
to the to the city if you so wish
but we also wanted to try and expand it
a little bit further
in terms of um you know we could
actually develop
then the experiences around our area um
i personally think that walking cycling
nature
bridal paths we've got in abundance we
don't really promote as
well as we should do but we could also
move that little step further to
the experiences for younger people and
speaking to
uh our intern you know having
experiences like rock climbing and you
know
other outdoor pursuits um you know
people go to sheffield to rock climb and
actually we could be doing that kind of
indoor activity here with the right and
supporting
with investment um so
like i said i would be interested to
hear about what your views and on the
vision is
um so why the visual economy um
why would we put it sort of fairly
fairly prominently within
um i've mentioned about how you know i
think we are locally
centrally located and i do feel it's
incumbent on us to try and
promote the events and the attractions
that we have got
i think we owe it to our local um
to our local businesses and don't forget
well
we might about 360 we can identify there
are many
other businesses which support the
tourism economy
whether it's downstream activity whether
it's support to public restaurants and
food supply and agriculture
so there's a lot of um a lot of support
for the sector
we we started to write this before
colbert and of course
with covert i think this strategy is
even more
important just by way of just looking at
the session now this was in 2017 but
you know we had according to the steam
report which is the report that that
is used nationally um made it to put
into areas we've got about
in 37 about 1900 it should force 2 000
full-time equivalent jobs
that probably rose actually since 2017
although i suspect that's gone back down
um in the wake of kobe but the sector's
worth 147 million
um 75 of of the our
mr coming was day visitors uh and
you know we could actually do more that
we get people to stay uh another night
it can trouble the amount of money
obviously that you bring to the economy
and 2 million visitors and
360 businesses in the sector that we
could find and there's
like i said we've smaller ones that we
haven't actually
um spoken to yet
so in terms of um uh just the
impact on covid um we we have known that
this has been one most devastating times
for the whole sector
and and its supply chain it's definitely
one of the hardest hit sectors of the
economy
but interestingly um some
some um companies in the tourism and
visual economy
sector have actually done quite well
in the time they were allowed to be open
so so as you know we have more wood of
opportunity where we could
go away and of course you couldn't
travel abroad which meant people having
staycations has been a massive increase
of
motor home use and camping and that's
probably quite good for people who
haven't spent time
exploring our district uh and indeed
nationally
um that we we did see that some
businesses who were able to not just
tourism businesses who were able to
adapt quickly to
digital technology uh were able to
um compete and somehow much done
extremely well
and so that was an interesting take
about the importance of um
you know in improving a digital presence
and
we're having that conversation in terms
of skill strategy and economic growth
strategy
before covid and i think actually
kobe's accelerated quite a number of the
um
concerns we had in terms of upskilling
and actually
improving growth and productivity uh
so um in terms of actually making this
happen though there is oh yeah i'm just
on the impact so we've got
we've definitely got a um
opportunity to actually make more of our
of our local areas because using green
space
walks cycling and getting away and
getting out into the country
um is definitely been the flavor of the
moment so
it is worth actually trying to
capitalize on that
partnership so like i said we do work
closely with marketing peak district in
derbyshire and
um chesterfield toys and hubs and things
but
marketing peach stuff was a huge um
operation
but to to go on their website you do
have to put quite a bit of money in to
improve your
your marketing profile and actually we
we think we could perhaps um support
people more locally
and we need to start really with them
getting people actually working for us
got an intern another one who's meant to
be joining us soon
um but hasn't done due to cobra but
really a tourist moss is what we need
to in terms of helping us to identify
um the the key the key areas for growth
and i think in terms of partners we
obviously
we do work well with um dcc um
we'll continue to do that martin pete
district tim derbyshire
aimed to be what's called a torture
matching zone and in doing that that
will hopefully bring
more money into the local economy which
hopefully gets support from
from the county in terms of helping with
infrastructure so a bit of
infrastructure better transport links
digital connectivity are all things that
um
that will help make our make our um
actually much better offer also
things like towson the opening better
high streets um
outdoor living and um walking in
pursuits
you know we know that um the county and
um others are trying to work with us we
need to get
a better understanding about what we
offer from the county in terms of the
walk
so we're working on that so our
priorities
that to promote the district to visitors
not just day travelers we do want the
overnight stays so actually encouraging
better better bed and breakfast airbnb
small boutique hotels
i see lots of properties that i think
would be perfect
for a boutique hotel um and you know we
need to make sure that our planning
supports this so having a policy means
that we know we try and
encourage rural um businesses and farms
and agricultural that you know to expand
some of their offer
developing barns and things to to bed
and breakfast
and we definitely need to actually um
help
increase the uh you know the
the people could see the cultural
heritage and just have a better platform
that can actually
showcase some of the great things we've
got in our area
and also through the skills of business
and owners that's part of our school
strategies as a crossover theme
um and actually trying to get people a
bit more tech
tech savvy would be very very good so
the action plan
um i won't read all that out to you um
hopefully you have a chance
to to read that or you might have a
chance already
and um i think hopefully
having a baseline and having a tourism
officer will definitely
help support the tourism economy which i
think will
grow
that's the end of the final presentation
thanks caroline thank you very much for
that
um and just scroll across see if
anybody's got it has anybody got any any
questions for carrie any comments to me
susie it's gonna bring you in yeah no no
fabulous carolyn i'm
i'm mega excited about this it's gonna
be brilliant
um i'm really glad you've grabbed hold
of it and you're moving it forward
sorry did i understand you correctly you
you're looking to employ
a tourism officer and is that person
going to
permanently based working on northeast
districts
yeah yeah i think i think we couldn't do
without
it we we definitely need to help support
the the sector
more now than ever and yeah the idea is
that the first thing we need to do is
create a baseline
so we we've highlighted in the i don't
know if you've actually seen the
strategy i don't know if the
chair you can i don't know if you
actually saw the draft strategy and they
went to cabinet
last week so you might not see it but
we've tried we've tried to put
um as many of the uh the the the
i mean i've got many showing there
cherry hall and scars down the hall
we've got the various golf courses
with so much more out there we don't
know about i'm positive of that
and so actually and and just walking
trails and walking
festivals and cycling tracks and there's
loads of things i know that we've got to
offer that we just
i didn't know about myself so it's
really about trying to get um
these like you know it helps with our
tourism helps bring people to this and
it creates jobs so
yeah a full-time visitor economy officer
is what we
were what we're aiming for fabulous
can i just say one thing um
and i'm i'm really sorry because this is
a very convoluted
pathetic comment but i need to make it
so about a year and a half i want to
engage sue
in this conversation about a year and a
half ago to two years
ago the growth strategy the growth
scrutiny
engaged specifically about this topic
tourism do you remember it so
yeah and we had the most amazing
presentation
by the most obscure man
who i'm sure was attached to bolsover
and he had something to do with website
and i i i can't tell you carolyn
how much i want his brain power
to be connected with your scrutiny
your your strategy and if sue can help
us get you two together
because i don't know if sue remembers he
was out
sorry counselor is this andy he from dcc
who worked with bolsonaro that you're
talking about with his cycling network
that was it he was on the bus it was
unbelievable
won it do you remember it it was
absolutely so
powerful he bowled us over
much more than anyone else we've met
and if i remember a report was going to
cabinet
around about that time and we did ask to
be linked into that
that's right if you if you remember uh
carolyn i sent you the the little
um say the better word
i've got my notes here let
when we were talking about it in the
previous administration so
that's not bringing in any any balance
council but i can't
can look back
he was the most amazing did he was all
about how he's gonna promote
it's amazing was it scott chambers
yes it was
yeah well done thank you carl
because he was absolutely honestly
carolyn
i can't begin to tell you how phenomenal
he was
yeah yeah well i've definitely made i'm
always concerned
of my radar teamwork if he's watching us
now
two or three things really uh one yeah
it's obviously got a good start carolina
i'm taking it it's the one that was sent
last week the uh
the draft the the uh
the thing there are a couple of things
on there you know
you're asked us for
just just to get there's this peak
resort that's starting up
so trump fringes it it's sort of runston
area
that carolina won't know more about it
than me but if and that whatever that
gets going
that will be a a right result for us
i think i think most of it's classed as
chesterfield but
struggling to interact that'll be really
good so
i think about it
yeah uh because i i don't see that
uh and and there's this sort of stuff
well i will be parochial but but
wingfield's got quite a lot of history
with the church and
i know eckington and killer master
church has been mentioned but
wingfield church has thought to mention
it doomsday book and uh
it's been there a long time uh it's not
it's not something that
it's a tourist attraction as such but it
is a lot of history to it
and similarly with clay cross which i'm
sure you're aware of with the
heritage around that because the people
laughed
when when we made clay crosstown center
heritage started thing
the victorian sort of structure there is
is some and george stevenson and the
tunnel
and all that sort of stuff and and
finally
just just hopping back i were expecting
later for his handle because i know me
and lee have
talked about this and he alluded to it
earlier
is that is the working together with
county council and
and the connectivity that's not the rit
connectivity it's the
cycle path connectivity from the avenue
to to took five pics and and all that
there's a lot of work going off there
but i've only come on to it last off and
i know leigh's been involved with a lot
longer than me
but there's a frustration there that
it's not progressing very well
and i'm and there's i think the the main
stumbling block is the county council
so i've got both that's on in this one
but
i want to try and make it happen because
and leo tell you better than me but
there's a there's a
there's a chance we'll lose some money
from the because it's been stalled that
long there's
there's some money's flying about i'll
let lee tell you about that
that if if it don't progress soon
that money might be lost uh yeah that's
a good chunk of money that
that we need to make happen it does link
into all this
that's a fantastic thing the circle
routes then
round chesterfield will be fantastic
absolutely fantastic you could travel
40 50 mile without virtually touching a
road if if you know what you're doing
and and that'll attract a lot of
cyclists walkers or whatever
so we are frustrated about it mainly
uh but again if if lee wants to comment
better than me
uh because if we can unlock that
gil looking at you or anybody
then then so we thank you um
i i i'm well aware of what's going on
with that psycho written we've been
trying to unblock it i think we've got a
response
this last week um but i don't think it's
the response we want
we want progress yeah so i think um
if any can if you're i'm saying
the blockage is uh we we need county
to move this forward we're doing as much
as we can so anybody that's
got a county connection um
please use it um and we are great
yeah i'm trying my best
yeah but we're raising it up there
because it needs to be done and i don't
want to lose any money it's really
important
it's really important i'm completely
with you right yeah right back to you
councillor barker but yeah two things
well four things so pete resort
i was so sad when i realized this was in
chesterfield because i thought
this was ours i thought this is gonna be
marvelous how exciting
uh but it is on our doorstep and i was
trying to think about what we could do
um support you know what what people
would come to this area
it's like um i suppose going to some
other well-known
lodges which they're quite expensive i
think the thing about
about north established i suspect we'll
have lovely
bed and breakfast and accommodation
that's not as expensive
and but nicely convenient with nice
small towns
and i do think we need to try and build
on the experience so this adrenaline
park that's at peak resort sounds
amazing um
but there's always room for smaller less
expensive
you know some some people don't want to
spend uh 50 quid to get into that and to
the governor's kind of this world and
and all these big theme parks we can do
some smaller good outdoor fun uh
more locally so that's something i've
got my eye on and there's a you know a
couple of people who want to do glamping
locally but the planning
the the planning function has support we
need to get more
than in breakfast and accommodation and
and stop blocking them
um also clay across your right the the
in terms of the the what's been
mentioned in the
report this was actually jill's first
email to all councillors
on her first week she actually you know
we were that's how long
ago i acknowledged that yeah we've been
working on that since then
and and we i didn't i didn't want to
offend any council or
councillor by not putting some amazing
bit of
tourism attraction that we didn't know
about so that obviously it might not
make the final cut in this draft
document but
that's the whole point that the mr
economy tourism officer is that
everything will be on there the
ambitions have a nice
interactive map that you can click on
and get some details
of all the all the offers and you know
we do we can't compete with
marketing peak district and derbyshire
all the tourism board things like that
but we can
definitely get we need to get a bit more
tech savvy at the district
and our on our website and our platform
so that's the long-term ambition
uh the internet's comes great because
she has a different perspective from a
younger angle what would be doing better
for younger people
really important to listen to to younger
people but yes for me
you know walking and cycling and all the
things that people come to you know
i'm the boss of the valley to big hills
people love it around here for walking
and cycling
for the nature reserves the fish and
cons i am actually
quite angry that it's taking so long for
the county to get this because
if this had been done 12 months ago
during lockdown would have had nice
um you know i i imagine that having
these
cycle trails years that i worked in
barnsley
on all these cycle tracks they used to
have really nice brochures
which i i'd like to see again something
that's foldable obviously now you're
probably in an
app and probably on your phone or you
you know your watch
great but then you know we should be
making sure that on that
as they're crossing through northeast
derbyshire that they're going to the
local cafe on the
on the path and they're stepping into a
business community so all that is
definitely for me
um is what this is going to be about
long term so
and i'm right behind you i've been kept
informed of the
blockages that's unforgivable um i don't
know how difficult it is
to get that mapped out digitalized and
sent out to all the various groups
and i share paul um council heart
shawn's
frustrations on that thanks kerry nick i
didn't know she had your hand up a while
back sorry i've not
forgotten about you that's okay thank
you yeah just a quick one really
for carolyn um obviously we've got the
um the train line the barrow hill
train line um touches on eckington and
killer marsh
um great for tourism obviously and stuff
like that so is that on the radar
that actually manufactures that that at
the moment's come under the just the
growth strategy
um but the the for me the the whole
point about those having a
retail offer around so it would go
probably would go on there
so early stage you didn't put it in i
did put in the the chesterfield canal
though in here because we are
you know we are quite a number of groups
and think things will happen on the
chesapeake now whether we get
the ambitions of what we want in killer
marsh i don't know yet you know it's
about the funding we're not the main
body but we would
be absolutely supporting that um canal
side
developments usually bring in jobs money
and
and tourists tourism so but yeah that's
it's to be on our radar and we're fully
supportive of the barrow hill line
i'd also probably add there that we do
have well i presume we have land
um as a district and working with
parishes as well that may have some land
that
um gets close to or is appropriate for
the canal or the uh train line so
um you know it's working it's working
together to try and
come up with some really great ideas um
you know to invigorate things you know
and rather rather
than let something like this passes by
um because it is a once-in-a-generation
thing you know laying a train line down
and a canal
the pretty generational things
yeah thank you yeah couldn't agree more
on it and they they're but
there are major major projects we don't
lead on them but we certainly should be
um from the center
jill i was just gonna yes thank you i
was just gonna stand the barrow hill
line
um the uh that's been uh
re-led by sheffield city region
um and the the metrics for that are
around
um joining up for for jobs and
which is why it sits better in the
growth strategy than it probably does in
the tourism strategy
um it goes it's going to go past the
length of time for this
um this strategy and the growth strategy
but you know
it's going to be in the growth strategy
which is probably where it sits better
so
just so you know it is captured
thank you john thank you
right i can't see anybody anymore hands
up
there thanks carly very much for that
sorry
as well oh sorry lee can i bring you in
first of all then
is this screaming yeah yeah i've just
been listening to everybody really
um but yeah with regard to this
connectivity i've
i've got involved really to do with the
uh
big local which we've got money to spend
on this project
which they've a lot of uh
a certain amount of money to go to
improving the pathways and what have you
and the connectivity towards uh the
avenue and basically
nothing's happening and that derbyshire
county council
are really letting the side down on this
um
i've i've had previous minutes sent out
to me martin
anthony sent me previous minutes out and
then we've just had an update
this friday and basically nothing's
happened and that's since october
from the last lot of minutes and it's
just the same
same detail comes out every time and
that's why i was saying earlier on
how do we influence
these other authorities to actually
um that we're supposed to be working in
partnership with
to actually get this work done and move
this this affects three wards this
affects tookton
wingworth grassmaul and then it also
affects obviously
chesterfield uh with aslan so it's quite
a
big uh and it's also
down from mill lane offices so i think
we ought to get this
done um but it doesn't seem to be going
anywhere
and we want to it quite clearly says
that they want
you've got a three-year project on this
uh like a three-year
development um
and i can't see it moving forward unless
[Music]
it's it's like the uh the tail wagging
the dog at the minute
they're not getting anywhere i i know um
council of our leaders knows about it
and he was pursuing it so hopefully i i
have a feeling it's staffing uh
internally which is very difficult
you've got an expert that's not there
um but it's definitely being raised
and um i'll we'll raise it again today
verbally i think
i'm sorry i knew something had come on
friday
i didn't realize it wasn't giving you
anything else so
with that right if that's not really
helped and
solved your issues then i'll have
another conversation
thanks carly thank you sue
thank you chair i i just wanted to um
wrap it up before the officers leave
because if you if you remember this is
the last meeting
we were looking at this strategy as part
of the review process
and um next meeting you're going to
triangulate so
um at the last meeting you post some
questions to the officers
uh which you wanted to be sure that you
you understood what you'd heard over a
number of weeks
so you could triangulate your evidence
um next
next meeting so if i can just remind
members what those were
um you wanted to know that the new
tourism strategy
is what you need and obviously you've
heard a lot of evidence uh in support of
that today
uh you wanted to understand um
whether what we were doing to help
tourism businesses
uh recover after the pandemic you know
what we've done to support that to date
and has it been effective and what more
could we do
and you uh wanted to know
how do we understand this and know that
it's working
you wanted to be clear that you
understood the
current delivery arrangements for
tourism within the district
and that we were clear on our direction
and offer
you wanted to know how we can increase
jobs and spending linked tourism and how
we identify that
um and you also wanted to know you know
from what you've heard do you understand
the economic benefits we're getting from
tourism
and finally you wanted to know are we
promoting tourism effectively
or do we need to do more uh on that
and as i say i know you'll have got a
lot of information today but you wanted
those questions to be sure that
you could triangulate at the next
meeting
right thank you sue thank you um
right scan across everybody seems quite
happy
yes thanks again caroline oh nigel
young sorry i'm just computing that
in fact i'm looking at nate to for his
end up first or hopefully he'd
computed it better than me uh
can we just revisit some of that sill so
what you're saying at the next meeting
we want to
start bringing some recommendations
forward on the
tourism strategy is that what you're
telling uh not just the tourism
strategies you know you've been
undertaking this review about tourism
business and non-business
and at the beginning of the process you
put your project plan together
and these were some of the things that
you wanted to be sure that you had come
to conclusions
with when you finish this review because
at the next meeting
if i can remind committee how this um
progresses you have a discussion on what
you've heard
and then you formulate recommendations
which
we write up in the report that then goes
to cabinet
for them to hopefully accept those
recommendations so they can be
implemented so we posed these questions
last time taken from
that project plan and some of these i'm
sure you'll say i've been answered
but obviously this was the last piece in
the jigsaw
and so i'm just reminding you what you
wanted to make sure you understood
ready for the next meeting so that you
were clear you could
do your report to make your
recommendations
does that help well yeah yeah i mean i'm
not sure as
as i've personally quite arrived at that
but
in same breath if you say well who else
do you want to talk to
i ain't going to answer to that one
either so we're i think
we're where we are aren't we it is what
it is i think is there is there are
saying at the moment
yeah and that and that is right council
the reason you do that is to ask that
very question
do we speak to anyone else do you feel
you need to talk to anyone else
and if so who because if that is the
case then you would do that before you
triangulated
the evidence no no okay i've got it
i'm computed
right thanks nigel i think i think we
what you asked is we all think the same
things it's
you're not on your own days it's um
it's been it's been a long process
really uh anyway
thanks carolyn like i said he was very
successful uh i think everyone it went
down really really well
um and jill too thank you
moving on to the next item on our agenda
and that is
forward plan of executive decisions
that oh carolyn no no saying thank you
i'll i'll i'll go
oh sorry everybody and
feel free to come back next next 24
hours on any views on the vision
all right thank you just keep on to alex
he's got more influence than me at the
county council came along
oh i didn't i don't believe that at all
i will do i promise you
i'll i'll have a conversation thank you
bye-bye
got time for a short comfort break
yeah is everybody all right with that
sure we're finished we're nearly
finished don't we
we are we're about three minutes away
which oh well
okay
right uh executive decisions two do we
have any anything on on this
now chair this is the usual uh report
that you get every meeting it's just to
let you know
key decisions that are going to happen
in the authority over the next uh
four months usually most of this stuff
we do pick up food mechanisms but it's
just if there's anything within this
committee's remit
that you had some additional questions
this is the point where you could raise
it and i would forward it back to the
government's team to chase cells
thank you sue thank you for that work
program
uh suppose that's that's you against you
isn't it
so just really to move on from what i've
said firstly you've got
partnership activities in support of
growth um is your first item on the
agenda next meeting so that will be
steve lee the strategic partnership
coordinator but then the main the main
thing of that meeting will be to now
triangulate all this evidence you've
heard and that's why i asked the
questions
because obviously you know you can look
at your past minutes and that will give
you a lot of evidence of what you've
heard
and i'm sure some of you have taken some
notes but this is where we will
you know have a um a session where we
actually identify
now and we do it in in three stages so
we do
best practice what you've heard that you
think is best practicing is working well
um areas for improvement where you
identify all those things that you think
we could be doing more
of or we're not doing at all or we're
not doing well
and then obviously that sheet is the one
that then hopefully guides you into what
recommendations you're going to make for
the cabinet
to improve tourism within our area
thank you right so that usually takes
about
anywhere between half an hour and an
hour chair so uh
if members can you know try and um
put all that together of what they've
heard over the last few months and it
has been
a long process but and if there's any
information that um
you want from me in terms of you know if
you've heard something anything i could
do with that document just having a look
at if you just send me an email i'll get
that back out
to you that's kind thank you thank you
for that
and can i just send my last thing chair
yeah
that will take possible now and stevie
would be about an hour and a half
so if there's any other item that you
want on that agenda we have
got a spare slot if there's any topic
that you might
want to do in that last well the next
penultimate meeting
okay cool thank you
uh item eight additional urgent
items has anybody got anything that's
urgent
and that is an item no that's good
um well finally then we've got to date
the next meeting
which will be the 22nd of february
22nd of february right everybody okay
with that
yeah excellent right in that case
i can uh say this meeting is over
thank you very much for your attendance
thank you sue damon welcome
everybody
you